there are four big levers in your
business that could be messed up I'll
show you how to figure out which one it
is and how to fix it so you can scale
your business we had those four levers
that I had earlier we've got traffic
we've got conversion we've got price and
then we've got churn so those are the
big four things and so if we want to
grow the business those levers have to
change or the business will not grow and
so for many of you it might just be you
need more traffic like the business
model is fine the economics are fine and
you need more traffic and so basically
at least my thought process that I have
with this is I try and scale as much as
I possibly can until something breaks
and then when it breaks we fix that
thing and then go back to scaling the
[__] out of it again I mean
fundamentally that's what we do and um I
mean I I teach this at at for for
businesses but I'll I'll walk you
through it what is going to go to these
four levers that we talked about earlier
right which is going to be your
traffic your two FS there whatever
conversion which is you tweaking your
about page making a vsl that's better
adding Carousel images tweaking the
bullets that you have on your landing
page uh you've got the price which you
can test and then you've got churn right
which has a big list of things that you
can do so these are the four levers the
things that you're doing have to Lad up
to one of these four if it doesn't lad
up to one of these four things why are
you doing it all right so like if we
were to translate your objective with
the free group you would have to say
okay I think that the US reactivating
the free group will increase traffic
that's fundamentally what you do it you
want this traffic source to make you
more money from your to towards your
ticket High ticket thing and you say
okay how much work will it take me to
reactivate this group okay is there
anything else that could get me more
traffic than reactivating the group of
the things that I have available so
right now could me just spending more
money on ads or making better ads make
us more than me spending the time to
reactivate the group if so forget
reactivating the group make better ads
or spend more money on ads does that
make sense so once you figure out and
when we're picking which of these three
things four things that you're doing the
thought process is what which of these
is the biggest constraint in the
business and so if conversion rate let's
say for example on the on the landing
page is super low then it might mean
like hey before getting more traffic I'm
going to I think I can double my
conversion on this page because I
haven't really spent any time on it at
all okay well then it makes sense to
spend a day or two like can I really
clean this up and make it as crisp as
humanely possible with the language that
I use can I grab screenshots that are
more meaningful that like you probably
had more testimonials things like that
you haven't updated like can I put that
on there can I make an actual 3-minute
vssl that that is more compelling than
the one that I just like tossed up there
okay that's probably a day of work well
it's probably high leverage because I
can double the growth of the business by
just improving this conversion metric
pricing like well if everybody just pays
you more we already went through that
example over here um this could
obviously make you more money and then
you have your big list of things that
you're doing for turn and so cool which
of these is the biggest uh thing that's
going training the business you pick the
one that you're working on and then for
me I tend to think through this
more better new and I tend to do it in
this order most of the time
so like I will just ask one of our
portfolio is like why can we not just do
more of what we're currently doing like
whatever we're doing why can't we just
do more so you'd have to make an
argument to me that we should reactivate
this group rather than just spending
more money on ads and you have to make
an argument that it's easier and it will
make us more money than spending more
money on ads and if you came with the
argument that' be like well then forget
about it if we can't do anymore for
whatever reason we have some limitation
like we can't post more than twice a day
on Instagram like we just can't or we
can it just like we've seen that when we
post three times it doesn't doesn't heal
the same performance so two is kind of
The Sweet Spot fine all right then what
can we do to make it better right okay
because if we can make those two posts
just higher quality overall can we like
really think through the hooks can we
make sure that they're tight that they
appeal ideally to the audience that
we're looking for if we do better then
the quality of the traffic will go up
the more views will go up does that make
sense now if we can't do any more any
better then we need to try something new
and you notice that most of the times
you can do more of what you're doing you
can do what you're doing better which is
why I so rarely do new things once you
have something that works that's the
hard part once it works it's like how do
we scale the living crap out of it and
the reason that most entrepreneurs in my
opinion especially small ones get stuck
is that they find something that works
and they stop doing
it and then they get distracted by six
other new things and they get completely
spread thin and it's and like what's
ironic is that the small business owner
is the one who has the least amount of
Leverage and you have the basically your
your contribution your time contribution
to the the income of the business is
more direct than anybody else's
especially at this level and so like you
like saying okay I'm going to take a
third of my time that might just be like
decreasing your business by a third um
and so you have to have a very strong
argument for why that's going to make
sense and then for who once you have a
team then that becomes the the next
thing it's like okay we know we going to
increase traffic the way that we're
going to do that is like we can't do
more posts on Instagram so we're going
to make them better and this is the
process that we're going to focus on
getting better which means that uh once
a week I'm going to take three hours and
and I'm going to script out I'm going to
look at other people's you know content
that have really good hooks I'm going to
write down all the hooks and then I'm
going to make content that I think is
going to appeal to my demographic in a
better way cool now who's going to be
you know if it's you then you're the who
in a lot of these if the business gets
bigger then it's like okay Jeremy you're
running this and then we just measure to
make sure Jeremy does his job that makes
sense in terms of thinking through this
and so we just want to make sure that
what you are doing is going to map to
what's going to drive growth within the
business
and I swear to God so many times people
are just doing [__] that does not map to
this okay Red's
over one quick question on that the the
first four is there like a certain
priority that you would recommend for
like I'm a solo operator I'm doing like
50 a month P Toc offer is there like one
of those big four that you would
recommend prioritizing first start here
okay because this is how you have
lifeblood in the business so you have to
promote you have to acquire customers
once this is relatively consistent even
at a low level I then this is me how I
think through this now not when I was
younger normally I would just be like
just do as much of this as you can foret
everything else now it's do enough of
this so that we can keep working on how
do we how do we find the things that
people actually want versus what we
think they want and then there's the
things that we can remove like how can
we delete things how can we make this
simpler how can we make it more elegant
how can we shorten the the models that
we have I mean we're hiding classroom
for new people like think about this
like we remov three calls a week like
we're trying to take things away not
because we don't want to add it's easy
for us to add the value it's but we want
we want them to consume it and so
consumption should be the highest
priority for everybody here in terms of
making like how do they get value they
have to consume value right so
consumption should be the highest
priority and so um we start here until
you have enough flow going through the
system that we can see what they really
want and a lot of times these simple
things like the last semester I think we
went through a ton of depth of all the
things that you can do to reduce turn
right it's like so you experiment with
that and this might be months while
you're doing this I mean for context
school didn't hit like a like let's go
hypers scale until like recently and
this was years right of getting the
product right like obviously like
there's people coming in every day and
there was enough promotion that we
basically we could test and keep
learning but it wasn't like we don't
want the world to find out about it yet
because we want to get all these pieces
right once these pieces are right enough
then you go back here you scale living
hell out of it boom yeah it's great
so right now the question for you is if
you have really low turn I don't know if
you do but from what you were saying it
sounds like you have low turn
then then yeah do more traffic yeah do
more do better of what you're currently
doing so you're are you running ads yeah
so you spend more spend more and Mak
them better top 20% of my best customers
targeted towards them now that I have
that insight and then just keep making
that better and then just more more
better and then just spend 400 Grand a
month on ads yeah sure
I mean it's like an inside joke in my
business like he's just going to say
more better it's like y that's what
we're going to do this quarter just like
we did last quarter just like we did the
cor before we're going to do more we're
going to do better and if we do both of
those things we'll probably make more
money and then if there's something that
prevents us from doing more or better
then we fix that and then we go back to
more better does anyone have questions
about what they need to do for
this like like you need you're like okay
am I should I be spending more money
well if you're if your LTV is good in
terms and your and your and your CAC is
low then yeah I just keep spending
I guess for like low ticket communities
you know recently you had a video where
you went like seven things like a
handwritten letters on boarding exit
interviews yeah for communities on
school like which one of these would you
go after the first kirby I feel like you
have even more insight with you the
price sounds like the thing that's
moving at say again the price okay
because you've already experienced what
that's doing right you know the average
is around 20 you probably want to be on
the good side of that so figure out why
you're not
like I would talk to your customers
first like why did you cancel you want
to talk to the people that cancelled you
want to talk to the people that stayed
and you want to figure out what
differences they have and then if you
find the people that stayed did these
things emphasize those things if you
find the people that left did other
things remove those and so it might not
be price I'm just yeah it but you told
us so um maybe it's price so like
balance that and then
you know with your traffic you you can
drive more of that and then you can play
with about page conversion you can play
with that and then when you're bard of
those go back to retention CH I know I
can drive like easily way more traffic
it's just that I have a leaky bucket so
I want to fix it so I'm like wondering
if I should add the onboarding or you
know EV onboarding I think for sure is a
good idea and how would you execute that
for low tickets you do a group
onboarding and everybody who signs up
gets one group on on boarding that you
attend you do it once a week I think
people throw a lot of [__] in their
community and then they just keep adding
and then they think they need to keep
adding to make it better but it's not
true like overwhelm is the main cause of
churn think about the experience so how
many things in the classroom would you
say is like The Sweet Spot cuz like
right now I have like eight
maybe the honestly the hardest part I
found when improving anything is to
figure out what's actually wrong with it
that I've I've been working on the
school games funnel recently by the way
homos will be happy about this
um I figured out like what the problem
to try to figure out what the problem
was was actually quite difficult but in
the was my it was this guy I knew from
New Zealand who's a complete stoner that
had text me when hosi when hosi launched
the games he couldn't understand what it
was and I was not going to try to
explain it to him but when we came back
to making this improving it I was like
it turned out that he was the best
signal for it actually what the [__] is
the school games I wrote it down that
was the problem if you didn't know what
school was you have and you see an ad
from homos and he's talking about the
school games and some leaderboards and
coming to Vegas people don't know what
the [__] that is so I wrote down what
the [__] is the school games and I was
like that is the
problem so but that took me a lot of
research to to like mind right I was
talking to a lot of people I was doing
this with Kirby it's quite an
interesting process right and then we
were like okay well how do we describe
this damn thing in a way that is make
sense to like a stoner dude um because
it helps to use extreme cases like Steve
Jobs tested products on children because
like if they could understand it anyone
could understand it right
so like defining the problem and then
coming up with different ways you could
solve it I've been doing this with goose
and Kirby in the office all week we
probably designed we came up with many
different ways to describe what it is
many different landing pages many
different bullets and we just kept
talking to users getting feedback and
kept iterating it we probably made 30
versions some of them were so wrong it
was I wondered what kind of
tangent you'll never see
it but you know we actually at the end
of about one week we landed on something
and um and now everyone we show it to
instantly gets it it's like we don't
actually have to fully launch to find
out when you learn how you can use
everyone to get like feedback and talk
to people and show it to people and get
their reactions you can do a lot of fast
iteration Cycles without the harshness
of like reality then when you launch it
into reality you have a way better
chance right um so that's how you
improve anything like that that's not
the games but that's what we were doing
to the games recently we Kirby was doing
interviews with all of the winners that
was overwhelming not many people were
showing up so we cut that we just did
one hosy Q&A a week right attendance is
up every viewing is up people are now
saying that it's way more
valuable and you know so it's
we were unlocking the one day recordings
after you got three customers we like
why are we making it hard to get the
most valuable
thing now you just need three members
they can be
free right so like what do people value
how do we make more people experience
that what do people not value take it
out what do people not understand reword
it you see it's all the same but I I
will I will I will emphasize what Sam
saying is that there's a it's so much
more work than you expect it to be and
everyone wants like the one silver
bullet that you're going to magically
fall on it but if it were obvious you
would have already done it and so it's
like it's disguised and that's what I
mean this is literally what makes
business hard and so I'll have a
business owner on a Q&A call say like
what should my price be and I'm like I
don't know I'll walk you through the
process of how I'd figure it out but I
don't know your avatar I don't know your
traffic scource I don't know the value
prop of your community and even if I did
I would say I'll start here and I'm
going to do the math and I'll move it
and I'll do the math I mean with the
portfolio same thing I it's like we
tested 50 35 25 15 we just tested it I
was like I don't know we'll find out and
then they were all the
same and then I was like okay well which
business would I prefer and then we go
into that right and so just just in
terms of thinking through things like
the amount of effort that goes into it
that most I would say that like as I've
gone as I've G moved up in business the
my understanding of the level of effort
that's required to solve complex
problems has gone up
100x it's just significantly harder to
solve more complex problems and that's
also why the biggest paydays are on the
other side of those problems because if
they were really easy to solve everyone
have already solved
it so it's like four hours in a cup of
coffee and a bunch of data and you're
like all right let's try
this there's a quote I learned from the
software engineers at school they say
you have to make every detail perfect
but the only way you can do that is to
limit the amount of details that you
have so inside of the school games we
have eight videos all of them together
are less than 45 minutes one calls we do
one call per week and that's
it and once a month you get a download
from here the Mastermind that's it very
easy to explain to someone one call one
course one Mastermind a
month and there's 13,000 people in there
each paying 99 a
month and they get the school
[Music]
software I have a question yeah so
there's a fine balance between because
if you're a leader of a big Community
right if you're showing up too much you
kind of almost lose your power right and
if you do Q&A every single day nobody
want it's not special so how would you
balance Q&A calls making posts inside of
the community and just showing up and
like giving people attention like that
I'm sure there's a data answer for this
rather than me just guessing we can
probably find it out of like what the
the best you know Cadence is I'll tell
you I personally I think post twice a
month in school that's not planned I
just I just kind of poke around and I
see what people are struggling with I
made that Niche post because I was
really tired of people be like what's my
Niche going to be about and I was like
here's how you find your Niche and so
it's just like I just listened to what
was the like there's you probably
noticed this in your community it's
probably like a pro like a problem dour
it's like people just kind of glob onto
a single problem all of a sudden and
like I felt like I was seeing more and
more of that so I was like all right I'm
going to try and answer this and so then
you make that and then it's like hope
and if it does if you put the thing in
and then that problem still exists then
you didn't do it right so it's like you
have to do it again you have to make it
simple you have to make it easier
whatever it is you keep doing it until
that one goes away and then like the
next problem will occur and the good
news is that your customers will always
have problems yeah and so you just solve
them I can tell you a good thing that
works for
me um so I spend a lot of my time
reading what people are saying like I'm
trying to understand what things people
are struggling with so I'm not in there
just posting a lot I'm in there
listening the most more than anything
else most it would be like 90% it would
be like a lot of time is spent listening
trying to figure out what is going on
what should I improve what problems is
the community facing right then when I'm
pretty sure I've got those problems I'll
even talk to some pal users and I'll
validate do you think these are actually
problems right and then I'll make sure
I'm clear on the problems first okay now
if I spend now prioritize them what's
the most what is the most pressing
problem okay number one now just focus
on that at least I know if I just fix
that I'll add some value right yeah so
now I'll try to fix that and I will try
to fix that by research experimentation
Etc and then I'll come back to my
community and say hey I saw all you guys
were facing this it
sucks I fixed it here you go
[Music]
and that's how I like that's how you add
value seriously no like I have I have
this little template on my wall for
emails which is uh hey I made this thing
for you here's what it does good
afternoon enjoy like CTA like that's
like that's my email template like it
just makes it really simple like hey you
guys were struggling with this thing I
made this for you here's why it's
important goodbye the hard part is
finding the thing yeah like I said how
do we make the school games funnel
better well what's the problem with it
that's the real
question and it was some Stoner dude who
had the
answer yeah so you wouldn't have a
schedule of like posting daily or second
like every second day or definitely not
that's like a Henry Ford production line
for Community like we're not trying to
pump out posts fast that's not what
makes a robot it's not that's not a good
Community a good Community is something
that under stands your pain and
experience and delivers Solutions and is
fun yeah you right yeah and isn't
overwhelming and doesn't make me read
five articles a day right like value
Post Yeah cuz I don't want to read a
bloody article that's a pain in the ass
like I want a
solution or I want to
laugh one of them yeah I'm doing 17
lives a a week in my paid at the moment
so but my my feelings telling me to put
it in the free community but I mean that
might be stupid because I'm trying to
listen to what you guys are saying
you're saying no we're just doing one
now and it's like so I'm a bit the [__]
you know I think if you want to use all
that like all that so last last games a
ton of people I think it was last games
it was like it was like the lives games
it like everybody was doing like
Instagram lives might have been maybe
two ago um and that the thing is is like
we have to separate promotion from
so from a promotion perspective you're
doing lots and lots of lives you're
making lots of posts you're making all
this stuff oh no I understand I got you
and so my point is is like I would take
all that energy and put it into
promotion so you get way more people
into your community and then the thing
is is that you if you do 17 lives a week
externally it's okay that people don't
consume all of them because if they
consume one of them then they might buy
whereas if you're inside of the
community and you're doing 17 they might
be like oh I'm missing out on 16 out of
the 17 I'm not I'm not getting the value
if it's free your cost is time and so as
long as you deliver a return on the time
that they spend consuming your content
then they got they have a positive
exchange with you and so you basically
it's like you can never promote too much
you can put too much inside of the
community and so I would take some of
that Juju and put it externally to drive
more through the box I think H actually
did like the opposite like when he
increased the daily coffeee to like
nearly every day oh his churn like
reduced massively so I have no idea oh
he's messing me like every day and
trying to figure out like all kinds of
things around churn at the moment um I
my answer to him he keept coming up with
ideas my answer to him was talk to your
customers I recently was pretty public
about this is that like I widened my
content for I think either 3 or six
months I like started sprinkling in some
other other pieces I talked about how I
eat and like Lea you know how Lea and I
run you know being married and things
like that and the the the problem is
that you do get positive reinforcement
from it and so it's like he made some
stuff on relationships and then people
were like oh this is awesome but the
thing is is like the wrong people were
saying it was awesome and so what was
happening is my audience was growing but
it was growing with the wrong people and
so I had I mean I had this moment where
like sometimes you have these like I had
a a friend of mine come into a friend
acquaintance I would say flew in and was
like um he probably does 10 million
bucks a year and uh and he was was like
yeah you know um yeah I don't I don't
listen to too much of your stuff anymore
and he's like yeah I was Hardcore for
like six years um and then I I just kind
of um I guess it didn't really apply to
me anymore he's like I guess I'm not
really like your avatar and I was like
you're 100 most [__] Avatar like you
are exactly who I'm going after and then
I was like oh I'm a [__] and I just
basically it's like you you get you get
it's a balance like you want to listen
to customers but you also want to make
sure you're listening to the right
customers and so um I reoriented all my
my content which maybe some of you guys
have seen um and it's been 100% back to
business has been the the theme that we
have internally my guys now um is that
if it's not business we don't make it
just very straightforward like it can be
business adjacent so like if I talk
about you know prioritizing like tasks
in my day that can have some element of
productivity into it but it's like all
my examples are going to be business
related and so but by doing that when I
looked objectively across metrics for
site conversion opt-in Book Sales
applications to the portfolio all of
those metrics went up even though the
average view per video went
down and so it's like I'm not in this to
get famous I'm in this to make money
cool question um I wonder if anybody has
I this might be for everybody but like
has anybody done anything to when they
do have a turned customer to get them
back into being a customer or send a
funny gift you just send a funny gift in
a DM ask credit P you have you seen him
yeah ask him for his message he's
apparently got some message he DMS
people with a funny gift and it gets
people to reactivate just say it's like
something like leaving so soon is kind
of like the vibe is kind of yeah but you
want to get the funny gift of course
yeah and it's just within school yeah
okay so no email SMS or anything like
that our sales team has that for uh
ghosted leads they have a Kevin Hart
meme that's like I think that might be
it I think that's what he's using
yeah and uh yeah it like it gets higher
response rates than any any message this
is kind of for both of you probably you
say as well definitely some um but I
guess like when you're building you know
a startup um obviously you know you
might have sometimes you might have a
little bit lack of capital A little lack
of resources I guess how do you get a
players to work for you and with you and
how do you like structure comp
structures and all that so it like the
vision for the business has to be big
enough that smart people can fit their
dreams inside of it and so if you want
brains then you need people who like
they need to be able to believe that
their dreams come true within your
vision if it's again if it's like yeah
we've just got a couple groups that
we're running and we're making money
then it's like that doesn't like really
get me motivated if I'm intelligent I'm
because like the best people have
there's no lack of opportunity for best
people they have tons like you have to
think about this is It's a totally
different game like you're if you're
accustomed to taking people who are like
I really want a job all of those people
are irrelevant you have to be people who
are like in some ways you're competing
for them so the more you're competing
for a prospect like selling them and so
if you feel like like like I'll tell you
the funny one is like if you're
interviewing people where you're like
sell me on why I should take you if you
say that to somebody who's actually
really talented they'll be like I'm
good they just like they just don't like
I you have to respond to this offer
within 12 hours it's like okay I think
you hit the nail right there for me like
their Vision has to be our vision needs
to be big enough for their dreams to fit
into it you have to be able to say like
what we want to do is we want to make
music money into the standard for this
and then they have to believe with a
decent amount of certainty that it's
possible and so like how you guys
present like you are absolutely selling
them and so like I think Drew this about
on on a past one but everybody here
understands you know lead generation
lead nurture sales onboarding and then
you know retention Ascension right
that's the how you do with customers
right this is the exact same process for
an employee you generate applications
you nurture applications the sale is the
interview you onboard the employee and
then either retain them or Ascend them
it's the same thing and so you basically
have to understand the acquis like this
is when we get into scaling everyone's
like two three people are like what's
scaling is it's just where the inflow of
talent into the business matches the
inflow of customers into the business
and you have to have an exceptional
conversion process for attracting Talent
this is where brand counts double it
counts once on the front end for
customers and again on the back end for
talent and it becomes either a virtuous
cycle or a vicious cycle either destroys
your business you have a bad brand
because what do you think what like what
um like great talent will look at your
reviews and be like oh this is yeah
never mind it would work at a good place
so I guess and last question I guess
what what would be the best way to like
acquire Talent as it just building a
person or brand like in our field of
work cuz I don't think it's necessarily
like I can't I don't feel like I can
find the right people on LinkedIn or
something like that you know for what
we're trying to do it needs to be people
who are kind of like already kind of
entrepreneurs or people were in more of
like the sales or manager manager field
it really depends on what role you're
looking for but I can promise you that
very smart people are on LinkedIn do you
know how I
um I I looked I got invited to speak at
something and I looked at who else was
speaking there and I saw hor mosy was
speaking there and I was like all right
there's my
opportunity that was the first time we
met in person yeah honestly so cool how
long ago was
that one year before I spoke about doing
a deal m
but you have to like be strategic
sometimes
yeah and then so you have to kind of do
this old school networking thing which I
[__] hate
because that's like the only time I've
ever done that the whole deal was like
the one deal to never do that again um
but yeah you kind of have to do that I
had to start going to like these
software things I had to start to meet
some software Engineers I had to learn
about their world I had to ask people
about why does what do you hate as a
software engineer what do you like what
makes a good company what makes a Bad
Company you have to like learn
everything about it and network and do
that it really sucks honestly but if
you're serious about it I knew there was
no way I could build school without this
person so I delayed starting it by a
year just to find the
person yeah so I was like I'm not even
going to start until I find them like
that's how essential I knew they were
that's why I tell everyone to not do
software it's just because the scale of
how difficult it is to actually do it
right is so hard that
like no one basically no one does it
right even when you know even if you
know what you're doing most people can't
do it and most people who are quote in
the info world are like oh my info thing
is INS salable so I'm going to build
software and they just think that like
white labeling go high level means they
own a software company um
like but I mean right and or they create
some widget that someone else can
duplicate in 5 seconds that they did off
with an offshore developer that like if
it actually did work then that developer
would hold you Ransom and then what like
they just don't play it out two steps
and the code [__] anyways and it's all
it all sucks like yeah don't do it yeah
and some were like you're just you don't
want us to succeed that's why because
you're you're doing so I was like no man
I saw that Sam I put 5 years in it I was
like great okay I saw the metrics I was
like okay this is legit I SP all my
money and it's still wasn't enough
yeah I had to spend like twice that
again yeah you guys for that too by the
way that that's going to help a lot
apprciate this for yeah I mean the
personal brand thing is just good for
recr like if you have one it's great it
helps a lot um but at the end of the day
if the if the if the business that
you're trying to build solves a real
problem and you really genuinely care
about the problem if you find someone
else who also cares about that problem
they will be more likely to work with
you like that's fundamentally it
what do you sorry last question F what
do you think about creating a an offer
to train people to do what you are
trying to eventually staff for like how
I'm growing yeah like you know like in
yeah you know training there was a point
there was a point in time I had a closer
program I was training closers and I was
Staffing them you know what I mean and
then I was I stopped doing that cuz
there's so many closer training programs
but right now I really need growth
Partners people who can lead and manage
our clients and kind of oversee
everything what do you think about like
I know there's a growth operator thing
but they're not you know like in my mind
like they don't have all the skill sets
necessar what if someone you know
created a program to train people I
don't think you create another business
to software role okay depends if it's
like I know with a software
engineer no one's going to be any decent
in 10 years maybe a prodigy in six or
seven but like there's just no
shortcutting that like I mean my
co-founder done 20 so
the years matter and the same is true
with a lot of things like there's just
years so like but some other things
might be different like setting okay
yeah you can teach that closing yeah you
can probably teach that but these more
high level
strategic
things yeah that ain't happening like it
took me [__] 10 years like so are you
going to wait 10 years no yeah it's it's
like fundamentally every skill is
trainable the question is whether it's
worth the return on effort and the
resources to train someone with it if
you break things down enough you can
train someone to do anything it's just
that if someone lacks has zero meta
skills they don't know how to read they
don't know how to write they don't know
how to talk you could teach someone to
do all that stuff it's just why
bother so I'd rather take someone who's
already here and then just nudge them if
I can with you know proper training that
just Bridges the gap between all the
skills they come in with and then
applying that to my business you got
it cool appreciate it yeah
I mean the people's the reason that most
internet marketers in general can't make
money I'm sorry they they make money but
they don't make like big money is that
they just can't they can't they don't
know how to operate people and that's
usually because they need like a right
hand a true right hand who can who's as
good as
them and like Lea will never get the
credit that she deserves and that's fine
um but like the reason that all of our
stuff is so big is because she's so good
at at building like she's an
unbelievable Builder and so like the
culture of the team is rockid I mean the
guys will tell you like Lea really runs
the like Lea runs acquisition. comom
like I I really like she really does she
does likea runs everything like I I mean
I told you I have an empty calendar I
can't have an empty calendar and and
also have a business that's running
unless someone else is actually doing it
Lila takes 15 meetings a day she
operates she's she's coordinating things
between different departments she's
checking on portfolio company she's
having you know one want the people who
having some sort of emotional breakdown
about some craziness whatever um she
handles all that with a smile you know
what I mean and so but like I I I was we
were talking earlier like I capped at $3
million a year and then when Leela came
in 24 months later I took home 17
million in income
net and so the difference was that she
liked people and I tried to avoid them
and that was the problem and so she her
Leila's genuine Vision in life is to
build a company that people love working
at that's her whole like the whole
reason that she like she gets up like
her internal mission is to build a
company that people love being at every
day and so her vision just fits within
my vision and so I recruited her to do
it but like if we didn't do stuff that
she liked we' like she wouldn't build it
so I very much like especially the more
talented the people that you bring on
the more you like like they don't need
pushing like they know what they're
doing you just need to make sure that
they're doing it in the direction and
you kind of do this yeah the amount of
training that you have to give some was
is inversely portional to the skills
that they come in with so the more spe
basically the the less skilled the
person the more specific the
instructions Sam could basically just be
like hey can you just promote school a
lot and I'd be like yeah he's not like
hey could you make these posts and write
this copy and send these emails and run
ads and make the hooks like this like
that exchange has literally never
occurred like I don't even know if Sam
sees the ads before before they they go
out he takes me the he was like when
does the activation stuff come out and I
said last
Thursday no like for real like I already
did
it and then he was like I've seen this
and I was like yeah I've already been
thinking about that we've got something
coming yeah like we don't even I've
already thought about the next four
things and we've got things ready so by
the time we has the idea I'm like yeah
we got it don't worry do your thing and
then I'm like cool let me tell you what
what I'm doing on the media side it's
like oh [__] great like these are all
the things that I'm ramping up this the
system we're putting in place like we
changed our Cadence like things like
that it's like oh dope I don't even want
to think about YouTube so like if I had
to tell him stuff oh my God
like yeah but it's good to divide it
like that cuz I can just focus on this
stuff he can focus on that stuff Kirby
can focus on his stuff we have very very
good like division like that yeah the
amount of Direction you need to give
someone is inversely proportional to the
skill they have yeah someone could just
be like hey can you build this company
and be like sure people will complain
like if people it's always a sign of
notice when people complain there's no
communication have you has anyone had
this as an
issue um like with teams maybe a lot of
you don't have teams yet but bad
communication communication sometimes
it's always the
complaint yeah found it's interesting
that one
because you don't really need to
communicate a whole lot when you get the
right people like well mosy said like a
couple of words and I was like don't
worry I got it like what happen like
right but sometimes if you hire the
wrong person there's no amount of
communication that can ever make it work
and it's
exhausting and it just still doesn't
work I think I understood this I think I
told this at one of the previous ones
but how you know what a good culture is
is this story of Google in the early
days so Larry Page searched for
something and the ads that showed up
were not relevant to the words he typed
in he took a screenshot he printed it
off he got a red marker and he wrote
These ads suck he walked over to the
engineers and he pinned it up on the
wall and he tapped it and one of them
walked over and picked it Off the Wall
stayed up all night that night and
invented
AdSense which is is their which has made
them hundreds of
billions chill so he didn't sit down
with him and be like look I think you
need to do this and this and this and
maybe this he just said these ads suck
right is that clear
communication I mean to him it was no
but that's what good talent is you can
just be like this thing yeah do this
yeah you don't even have to say do this
you can say this sucks sort it out like
and and then they'll they'll be on it or
they might have already preempted what
sucks cuz they've already been thinking
about it so I always remember that when
people say oh like you need more
meetings or more communication like
there wasn't a meeting first of all
right there was there was slapping
something on the
wall yeah one of the most difficult
things this is like I think this from an
entrepreneurship perspective in terms of
development is like has anyone here had
another business before
this yes okay did you achieve in this
business what you achieved in your last
business like in like from how long it
took you to get to that level in your
the business before versus how long it
took you to get to that level with this
business was it way
faster and so a lot of the reasons is
because you already beat the bosses up
to that level so it's kind of like
you're quickly retracing your steps and
then you get to a level that you don't
to your level of incompetence the
difficulty the the thing that takes the
longest in entrepreneurship is figuring
out what good looks like at each level
and it's one of those things that's
really hard to translate like you see
the billionaires on stage and they're
just like I you know get great people
and you're like sure but the thing is is
that connecting what great people to
them looks like in their mind and what
you think great people are that is an
ocean apart and so I mean I tell this
story and Sam when I was talking about
this last time but like I when we
started meeting with private Equity
firms uh to to to look at transacting
with gym Lodge I we'd have these super
long tables that were these board roomes
and I'd see their team all the way on
this side I saw my team all the way on
this side and I would just kind of sit
there and listen to like the questions
that they were asking and the responses
that my team had to be fair the team
that we had had built $100 million do
plus company pre covid obviously I sold
during Co which actually hurt my
valuation but not the point um so they
built a $100 million company which is
cool but when I saw this the town on
this side I was like oh that's why these
guys are going to make $3 billion over
the next five years this team and it was
such a stark contrast in terms of the
level of talent again not disrespecting
my team it was just such a difference
that it was literally like after that
immediately I was like my whole bar was
just reset in terms of the caliber of
the people that even existed in the
world and everything was like how on
Earth do I get those people to work for
me and so like right now some of you
have like one person who's like man I
couldn't live without that person
there's somebody who's literally 10
times better than that person that
exists right now and it's just trying to
figure out what you you need to do to
get them on your team but the problem
that takes so long is looking at what
good talent in general looks like but
even when it gets role specific like Sam
had to do all this research to figure
out like how do good software Engineers
talk like what do they like what do they
want and so some of you guys are at a
point where you need to like start
hiring a sales director or something
like that like what happens is like this
is the entrepreneur on know it looks
like you bring someone on you talk to a
bunch of people and then you're like I
think this guy's good you bring him in
and he sucks and that takes six months
away from the growth that you would have
had because your sales team and this guy
sucked you put bad processes in then you
got to fix the process you got to fire
the people that guy hire cuz he sucked
anyways and then you're like shoot I'm
going to try again you bring the next
guy in and then sometimes it happens
again and you're like wow this sucked
and then the third time and sometimes
this takes a year or two years and then
you're like I now know and you get lucky
and you get one who actually works and
you're like oh this is what a great
sales director looks like and so the
next time you go through your
entrepreneur Journey like you go right
to there and then you're like shoot I
don't know what a good customer success
person looks like and then you try again
and so it's like however quick you can
work through that so you can start
recognizing the pattern of a what good
looks like in general and then B what it
what good looks like for a specific role
that's how quickly you move through the
levels that's been my experience with
this and I wish I try and do everything
I can to try and translate that into the
stories that I tell with the content but
sometime it's really tough because
people like nod but like that is that is
the secret sauce like that is it is
being able to recognize like what a good
growth partner looks like what a good
even a good agency I've have good I have
good agencies that we work with with now
vast majority of them 95% of them are
dog
[__] some of you guys run
them so like that's that's that's that's
the pattern recognition that's the
highest value thing that you end up
learning as an entrepreneur is what what
good looks like